[Music]
my book hitmakers is essentially about
the science of why we like what we like
and one of the most interesting answers
to that question is Maya MA why a most
advanced yet acceptable and this was the
theory of everything by Raymond Loewy
the father of industrial design in
America and a lot of people today don't
know who Raymond Loewy is but this is a
guy who was essentially kind of like
Steve Jobs meets Don Draper for the
1950s he invented or designed the first
I'll go back he designed the most famous
car design in the 20th century the 1950
Studebaker the modern train the modern
Greyhound bus the modern tractor even
that pencil sharpener that looks like an
egg that was his design and in thinking
about this question how could one person
understand what consumers want from
things as different as cars and pencil
sharpeners his answer was this maya most
advanced yet acceptable people are torn
between neo philia on the one hand they
like new things and neophobia
on the other hand they're afraid of
anything that's too new and he was this
genius essentially at combining
familiarity and surprise I think the
most useful way to think about the Maya
principle is to think of it as to sell
something familiar make it surprising
but to sell something surprising make it
familiar so let's take an example like
Star Wars George Lucas was working on
Star Wars for a long long time the
script was absolutely terrible he was
sharing it with his best friends like
Francis Ford Coppola and they were all
telling him that the script was absolute
garbage and he had essentially built
this incredibly surprising novel new
world filled with Jedi's and forces and
magic and creatures that no one had seen
before
and then he was reading this book by
Joseph Campbell on the monomyth on this
idea that every great story in human
history has essentially been the same
story of an ordinary person who goes on
an extraordinary journey defeats a
nemesis intimately involved in his own
origin story and then comes back to the
real world as the hero and so he said oh
this is it this is the story that
explains that is
Jesus that is Buddha that is the Odyssey
and the Iliad I'll take this incredibly
familiar structure and I'll put it into
this incredibly surprising world
building exercise and that is Star Wars
it essentially sells an incredibly
surprising world an incredibly familiar
narrative setting and I think that's one
reason why we like it it's not so much
that it's novel is that it's a novel
setting that is essentially telling the
oldest story known to man so it matters
where you're starting if you're starting
with an incredibly familiar product or a
really familiar intellectual property
like say movies and creating a movie
sequel the challenge for those writers
is how do we create a surprising new
story that will get people back to a
familiar character right but lots of
people are dealing with the opposite
problem they have a new idea and they're
trying to make it familiar to an
audience and the best examples from here
all come from technology I think about
the the first Apple Macintosh where
Steve Jobs famously said I need the
screen to say hello I need it to look
like a face he's creating an entirely
new product category that people aren't
really used to and so he understands how
critically important it is to take
something that is novel and to sell it
through familiarity this is a friend you
see the exact same thing I think with AI
assistants things like Alexa have a
lilting female voice which you could
argue is a sort of working with a
gendered expectation of an assistant but
it's still working in the same principle
to sell a really new technology like a
little nub that has AI intelligence
inside of it make it talk just like you
would expect an assistant to talk to you
I think about this issue also with the
iPhone most famously you know Steve Jobs
was not creating a product category but
he did create the most profitable
product in modern human history and it's
important to remember that the iPhone
did not look new it looked like a touch
I pod it looked exactly like a product
that Apple already had so when people
picked it up they did
have to think oh I don't know how to use
this how does it work
he essentially took an information
ecosystem that they understood and said
now it also does calls an internet and
so I think that it's really important
when selling a new product when taking a
new idea and trying to make it appealing
trying to make it popular to not think
about making that surprising idea as
surprising as possible because people
love to be surprised no take the
surprising idea and make people feel
comfortable with it make it feel like
home make it feel familiar and so I
think it's also interesting than just to
pose this idea with Google glass which
is Google's sort of famously flopping
product where it looked like spectacles
kind of but they had like a huge cube
here the point is that I think one of
the big problems with Google glass is
that it looked like a prototype it
looked like a toy for nerds and in fact
I went to X recently and wrote a cover
story about X I talked to a lot of
people who worked on Google glass and
they said the biggest problem with its
rollout is that we had a prototype for
nerds and we sold it as a product for
consumers and that was a mistake we told
people that this is the new iPhone that
this is the new product category that's
going to redefine the way that we
interact with computers in the internet
but that's not really what it was it was
a nice tool for manufacturing and
construction workers to put something on
that looked like goggles and recorded
their work and sent it back to
supervisors but stop for two seconds and
think who wears goggles on a daily basis
no one people were glasses but Google
glass didn't look like glasses they
looked like weirdo goggles and so I
think that it's really important when
trying to introduce new product category
to think as clearly as possible
how do I make this feel as familiar to
its core audience as possible
particularly when it's a bright new idea
and I think that Google failed
tremendously in that in that aspect
because they didn't understand properly
enough the habits and the familiarities
of the people that they were ultimately
selling to
you